- The first thing I
learned to play was a flam.
You start putting them
together, getting the flam
with a triplet, the flam accent.
Then it turns into a different rudiment.
You put a diddle, which is
the double note on one hand
on the flam, and that's called the cheese.
There's a lot of funny
names for percussion stuff.
(percussive music)
There's always more room for improvement,
especially with my SAT scores.
Some people come in talented,
but that's not enough.
The more you do it, the
better you'll get at it.
You would say talent, and you
need hard work and practice.
- [Man] Hey, trumpets!
- Push it with the toe.
- [Man] Come back to the bandstand.
- The point of doing that is so your brain
has that muscle memory, that,
like a second nature kind of thing.
There's no better feeling than practicing
that same, let's say, two measures
(percussive band music)
and finally getting perfect
like finally, I got it.
I can move on, this is
gonna sound amazing.
I know it's gonna sound amazing.
(exiting percussive music)